Європа в новому образі просто doris 2-е з
podorova в собі але в штаб-квартиру я
будемо в брюсселі і кому я назву Європу
прямо там азау строчи на найвищому
рівні йому вірна вже про персі підлозі ви
недоступному уроку
з клена конструкція формі куба прозрачна
сама до річок і травня ніби з якихось було
кисті століттям сава лізу я на ваші різьбленому
вони ті ж краще щура за камазі тицьнувся
континент урочищем інша
за крима micra кено щур і qaydasiz
завдаючи чим вона конфлікту qs brexit та
киз нори в європу укри за ідентичності
а також популісти
таки відривається пак і звичний типу
батю околицях ще проц думати європейці
проекти євросоюз ханим рейд на
прикінчити його щури го го року рахунок
turbo та їх на і більше якщо
університету багатий у людей не може
знаєте роботу ту багатьом до води тебе
проти ти офіціантом і про ресторани
тут-то у сфері обслуговування ви не можете
знайти досить гарний місця роботи
для жити від тулів
адже вона без біженців у Європі нас дуже
багато зі складною малюка довгий халат
для нас шумівка інтер'єрного їх дивуй
з навіть я з крави та кулеровий touch
івентисти ви добра нас три біг-6
європейців у мене за все я боюся відсікав
історик вона може стати 6 але і з
завди до споконвічного фасаду пари хоче
може по батчата голову але конференц-зал
у кору замість україни на vista нікель
кування раків та ще 2 березня покликана мати
чи то пак ейве відкритим і давати
людям знати більше про того, хто стоїть на
роблять
та акції владно спливаючи на жити а
громадян мої на приклади вена може
точно сказати ще саму роботу
єврокомісія обидва європарламент та арійці
травня на мене фліф дерек лімпити мін
Євросоюз обіцяючи ніби близьким до
громадян
проте проблема kevin моя подолати
доступний руку на багатий з цвинтар і
шобла що ваня нового фасаду doris 2
[музика]